قوات الأمن الفلسطينية التي تم حبسها
وتحميلها في مداهمة في مدينة نابلس بالضفة الغربية
أبلغت المخابرات للتو
الشرطة أن تاجر مخدرات معروف
قد يكون مدجج بالسلاح يتحرك ،
هذا رجل أرادوه منذ
بعض الوقت.
مبنى سكني فارغ ، تشكل الشرطة
محيطًا مكدسًا وتتحرك إذا
ظهرت التكتيكات مباشرة من
كتاب قواعد اللعبة الأمريكي ،
لأنهم عائلة ماهان أخبرني والسيد.  ألماس
منطقة الكابينة وفي قاعدة التدريب هذه
في أريحا ، تم تدريب الجنود والشرطة على
مدى أشهر لصقل مهاراتهم من
التدريبات الأساسية إلى إطلاق النار باستخدام ak-47
هنا ، حيث تقوم وحدات النخبة بالتدرب على إنقاذ
الجنود المصابين خلال كمين
وإشراك الإرهابيين.
جزء من أكثر
من 60 مليون دولار سنويًا
ساهم دافعو الضرائب الأمريكيون في تحقيق
الأمن الفلسطيني فائزًا آخر
لهذه الشراكة. إسرائيل ليس سراً
أن قوات الأمن الفلسطينية تتحمل
عبئًا كبيرًا على الجيش الإسرائيلي إذا كانت
السلطة الفلسطينية ستضطر إلى
التصرف بشكل أقل.  سيتعين على الجنود أن يتصرفوا
أكثر لأنه سيضع عليهم
عبئًا أكبر من أنشطة مكافحة الإرهاب ،
كان التعاون الأمني
قوات الأمن الإسرائيلية وقوات الأمن التابعة لل
لطة الفلسطينية اس
ثنائيًا بدرجة عالية من ال
حتراف وفاعلية للغاية وقد حظ
بتقدير كبير من كلا الجانبين إذا فقدنا ذل
يمكن أن يكون حقًا ضربة
للاستقرار النسبي الذي يتمتع به
p  شتم في الضفة الغربية على مدى
السنوات الماضية ، يقول بعض الفلسطينيين
إن التعاون يساعد
الاحتلال الإسرائيلي ويقول المسؤولون الفلسطينيون
إنهم يبنون الأساس
لدولة فلسطينية مستقبلية ، ولحظة روبن
مين ، أعني
جيدًا أن الغارة السابقة في نابلس
تظهر ما  تكافح قوات الأمن
بشكل يومي ، هذا هو ما
استعادوا ثلاثة كيلوغرامات من
المخدرات المختلفة هنا لدينا بندقية آلية للجيش الإسرائيلي
بالإضافة إلى مسدس
للقنابل اليدوية ، وأخيراً 900 طلقة ،
هذا النوع من القوة النارية
شائع ومن المحتمل أن تملأه.  الفراغ
في غياب الأمن الفلسطيني
يعود على رجال الشرطة في اقتحام
بئر السلم ، إنه متوتر لكن القوات تتحرك
بسرعة لاعتقال المشتبه به
وسحبه بعيدًا عن المداهمة بأكملها في أقل من
أربع دقائق ،
وهذا يمثل ضربة جيدة
للمسؤولين الفلسطينيين الإسرائيليين.  يخبرك